[Applause]
[Music]
happy thursday everyone
so crime is higher than me
it's getting so bad in california people
are leaving their trunks open
car trunks
with this crowd i should be specific the
perverts
but to avoid having their windows broken
they're just leaving the cars wide open
telling thieves to take whatever they
want
thankfully the mayor of san francisco
says she's had enough
of the behavior that she and others have
enabled for now it is time for the reign
of criminals who are destroying our city
to end
this time
that the reign of criminals who are
destroying our city it is time for it to
come to an end
and it comes to an end
when we take the steps
to be more aggressive
with law enforcement
more aggressive with the changes in our
policies
and less tolerant
of all the [ __ ] that has destroyed
our city
welcome back to planet earth
so it's bull poop that's destroying your
city
i don't know i take a look at your shoes
i'm pretty sure that's human
might as well start there i mean still
that some salty language coming from
someone who's proud this city believes
in giving people second chances
we are a city that prides ourselves
on second chances and rehabilitation
but we're not a city
where anything goes
our compassion should not be mistaken
for
weakness or indifference what i'm
proposing today
and what i will be proposing in the
future
will make a lot of people uncomfortable
and i don't care
at the end of the day the safety of the
people of san francisco is the most
important thing to me
wow did someone replace london breed
with an evil twin
you know someone who's competent
now it's not my job to say i told you so
but i can't stop it i told you so
god that felt better than a foot massage
this show has repeatedly warned her that
the city was in a death spiral but like
killmead when we asked him to lay off
the aftershave she wouldn't listen
the mayor refused to read the
handwriting on the wall but maybe she
read the feces on the sidewalk
although it's not breaking news that san
fran has turned into a haven for public
defecation
maybe it finally hit her street i wonder
which pooper sent her over the edge
so you're the guy that's forcing the
mayor to crack down huh what do you
think he did
well look i mean i've been in a lot of
people's backyards and i've hit them all
i mean joe montana barry bonds the guy
who sold steroids to marry bonds so it's
very possible that i hit her yard
without even realizing it so just
private residences oh no no i've hit all
the great spots in san francisco let's
see i've in the front yard of the house
from full house and right off the edge
of the golden gate bridge they didn't
even try to stop me uh alcatraz is on my
bucket list but spoiler alert i don't
have a bucket i also enjoy a good
backyard pool above ground only of
course i'm not a monster but
guys i gotta run the coffee's kicking in
and i gotta hit nancy pelosi's house
before dark
but look it's also wrong to criticize
someone like the mayor for finally
making the right decision just because
she could have done it far sooner
the fact is every right decision could
always be done sooner true i could have
quit doing drugs sooner but does it make
it wrong that i still quit later
or rather plan on quitting later
in the near future but let's be
optimistic the mayor's comments seem to
be affecting even the most stubborn
democrats currently living in a state of
denial that state being california
they've realized people are dying around
them or at least the people they finally
care about the rich white liberals who
make up their tax base i mean there is
an attitude of lawlessness in our
country that springs from i don't know
where maybe you do
there is an attitude of uh
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
thank you skeleton lady
so yeah that lawlessness mysteriously
grew on its own like your eight-figure
net worth i guess we should be grateful
you didn't blame us for it but the
violence springs from you don't know
where
i guess that fridge full of ice cream
froze what's left of your brain
because it's obvious to everyone else
far left politicians and media cowards
pushed for defunding the police as well
as policies that made crime an
alternative to living a good honest life
they even helped raise money for rioters
does that ring any bells for you yet
nancy let's not forget making
shoplifting a misdemeanor as long as you
stole under a grand worth of crap
the leaders didn't seem to mind since
these disconnected elites can't imagine
anything costing less than a grand
that's gavin newsom's weekly budget for
hair gel
it's the eternal democrat flaw a refusal
to see how their incentives for bad
behavior only create more bad behavior
they're like life coaches for criminals
they do everything to encourage them
except stand outside of zales with
pom-poms and cheer them on that's all
right that's okay just grab the drive
away
now they admit the city's being
destroyed and nancy's like wow how did
that happen
if her face could move she'd be shocked
or maybe pelosi is playing dumb since
she already made excuses for mayhem
remember her response to the mobs
destroying public property
i don't care that much about statues
respectfully shouldn't that be done by a
commission or the city council not a mob
in the middle of the night throwing it
into the harlem people do what they do
ah
people will do what they do says
princess frozen face
but i guess back then under trump it was
just easier to side with a mob than take
a stand against lawlessness but now the
mob has gotten what it wanted the city
is dying and pelosi's scared so this is
a change of heart or whatever tiny organ
still beats in pelosi's chest
and i hope it's real remember after blm
protesters demanded police defunding
breed announced that her city would be
the first to knuckle under with 120
million bucks in budget cuts to both the
police and sheriff's department she was
warned it could hurt the city but she
was more interested in appearing woke
than safe well i bet you're awake now
london
and what followed more open-air drug
dealing car break-ins car thefts retail
theft property crime and of course
murder
now others have said but property and
violent crimes are lower than historic
levels but that's because businesses and
residents stop reporting the crimes
because like kill me sending out
birthday party invitations
they never get any response
you have not even introduced me yet i am
waiting do you call man and also
criminals tend to hold a drudge
meanwhile in uh san francisco the rate
of arrest dramatically declined for many
crimes in 2021 19 of all shoplifting
reports resulted in arrest san francis
progressive d.a charged just 46 percent
of theft arrests a 16-point decline
since he took office and he charged only
35 percent of petty theft arrests that's
not a reduction in crime that's called
giving up
so now after all this breed is finally
changing her tune and urgently
requesting more dough for police and
while i want to say you could have done
it sooner maybe i should just say good
job better late than never and maybe
this can start a true awakening to the
destruction that woke policies have
wreaked upon every city where they exist
liberal leaders should be waking up and
saying
my god what have i done
just like anyone who hooked up with kill
meat in the 90s
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest he knows stock
picks like i know cake mix i eat it
right out of the box fox and group
founder and the author of the book
there's no pre-launch david boston
the christmas tree
the fox christmas tree saw him and set
itself on fire
bob's in frames co-hosting all
throughout the new book the president
and the freedom fighter brian kill me
alaskans raid his act slightly below the
exxon valdez ryder and actor and
comedian jamie lissau
and she's like a holiday fruitcake with
twice the brandy and just as many nuts
fox's contributor cat tip
how you doing there brian not as good as
i was before i walked in how did i make
your monologue twice without
contributing to the show how does that
happen oh you are my perfect punch line
yeah well with being president cheap and
easy laugh i say how dare you yeah no
i'm saying i i will take the cheap in
easy laugh you know you're pro crime and
do you support defending the police uh
you must be upset that mayor breed is
the change of heart i don't believe her
uh i don't believe her i don't i i
really don't think because
we're not that dumb nancy pelosi
suddenly realizing that crime pays he
goes these people aren't poor they're
actually taking this and reselling it oh
wow this is just she's 111 years old and
she just figured out what's going on in
her own town here's what i'm saying
things are so bad they have to change
but don't to ask the cops to change
giving them more money giving more cops
they're out yeah they dealt them out
they're out because they have no power
they certainly don't have her backing
and they're not going to do any arrests
until you change the rules and show them
sincerity you can hire as many cops as
you want
they are not in until they get the power
to actually do their job yes and if they
make the arrest why arrest anybody if
they're gonna be out on the street
before you do the paperwork they're not
working yeah i don't blame them i don't
blame them one second and uh it also
shows the desperation their internal
polls must show that they're going down
in flames with the elections a year away
mm-hmm you know jamie in the green room
you said let's just kill them all i
didn't know what you meant by them oh
yeah from the bugs the bugs yes the bugs
that were on the wall
just with the the panel we have and i
just want to let everybody know that um
i don't have a book out
i don't know that was a thing why did
why did these cities just let crime get
out get so out of control in the first
place it's it's so crazy it's almost
isn't it really sad to think you have to
pull your car up and
leave the trunk on it's like insane like
yes it's really sad and windows down and
windows i was in san francisco two weeks
ago i walked home with no pants on
because
i was worried about a pickpocket you
know what i mean
to be
to be totally honest that's just what i
came up with when the cop caught up
but um
it's really sad and putting the trunk up
i don't know if that's a good idea you
go like hey there's nothing in here but
if you look a little harder my
registration that's my address maybe
there's some nice stuff there yes
as a parting gift wants you to grab the
battery out of my hood yes it's true
it's true it's like if you're gonna
leave your car unlocked they're just
gonna find out where you live yeah it's
it's very scary unless like you you live
in the car i live in the car so it's
like oh hey get out of here
um
you know what's funny too like there's
there's obviously pros and cons to
everything and i know there's like a big
homeless problem in san francisco but my
buddy who lives there told me he's
saving so much money not having to
fertilize his lawn
because they're they're
on it yes
yes they're poop you know humans
somebody missed it no no we all got it
we're all just like you maybe we're just
pooped by the poop
i don't know what i'm saying david
welcome to the show you know what i
noticed
that
these cities didn't seem to care until
the smash and grab started hitting
high-end luxury goods places it's almost
like they could endure the murder but
they couldn't endure the like the
wealthy not being able to shop no i
think i think you're right she's a funny
lady by the way not just on this whole
issue the mayor of san francisco is the
one who was caught dancing at a wedding
without a mask on right and she said
everyone needs to be messed up and i did
take my mask off but i won't apologize
because sometimes you just got to dance
yes and yes the spirit moved in her and
i think that what her attitude towards
this crime thing is sometimes
criminals are just going to be criminals
po speaker pelosi had said that but um
no the it's very arbitrary and i think
that you're right it got into higher end
neighborhoods and then brian's point is
good i mean a year away from the
election they know this this point it
looked pretty good about a year and a
half ago uh celebrating barbarism
running as the party of the french
revolution uh it doesn't look so good
now yeah you know cat we're go you know
we have a new mayor coming in eric adams
he was a former cop uh and you have to
see these changes over here but what
about like what nobody is talking about
is the resistance from the their side
like the heart like the the the school
the board uh you know whatever they call
what are the support in san francisco
the the board of commissioners or you
know what i don't think the audience
knows or cares yes
school people yeah i don't know i think
they call it the board in san francisco
yeah
yeah i think you nailed you nailed it
the board of supervisors and that wasn't
whispered in my ear from a producer no
certainly not thanks uh
no i that's why i think i disagree with
you mr kilmeade um because i don't think
she had to do this i think that a lot of
people aren't doing this i think she
could have just you know she was saw
some new information and she used that
information to change her tone on things
people almost never do that right and
i'm sure that was really hard for her to
do especially she could have just come
out and said
on the sidewalks is white supremacy yes
right
[Music]
boom new york times column
you know because look at like it's
better than being corey bush and you
know quietly hiring private security for
yourself while continuing to say you
want to defund the police it's not
always easy to admit you were wrong but
she did defund the police she did and
how would she how she thinks it's going
to turn out well she she's
acknowledging
that it didn't she's not saying i messed
up at least she's saying we're going to
do something different people almost
never do that you know what she said
what kat and
it's like sometimes you just got to be
grateful for whatever you can get from
from these leaders right do you think
something's going to be executed from
here or is that a speech i don't know
and dana perino who likes you a lot she
will never admit that on camera yeah she
says that the cursing is all that's
contrived that's just when you're cursed
to show your convicted that's what dana
focused on the cursing right she said
though she said the b word
the b word i can't trust that woman
anymore and she's very learning dana's
got a filthy filthy filthy mouth
who's the only person on the five who
has sworn not me not jessie dana
twice
filthy filthy little farm girl
yeah
what were you talking about you're way
off track now uh it's talking about the
judge
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else